Hi, I'm Livia Wild.
I somehow got talked into being on Smartless.
So, I don't know.
This is a disaster.
Welcome to Smartless.
We love the eagle.
We la de eel.
Can you get a small, I love you, you get a nice small mustache and then start doing the,
We lave the only.
And I don't go full, like a little pointy goat.
Yeah, like, um.
We lie.
We love you.
What bella.
What a bella.
So, Sean, are those new specs?
Oh, yeah.
Do you like them?
Yeah.
Nope.
No, sorry.
I do.
I'm sorry.
You said that so quickly.
No, I do.
Yeah, look.
I do.
I like them.
They're nice.
Wait, who made the clear horn rim frames famous?
I feel like it was like a Ted McGinley or one of those handsome fellows.
You're welcome. I think I did.
Andy Richter.
Oh, Andy Richter wears them.
Andy's always worn them. Yeah, for a long time.
What did I just see Andy Richter is in?
He's an obsession.
Obsession, yes.
Yeah, he was great.
I love Andy.
Can I just say that just as a general rule?
We all do.
I know.
What's not to love?
He's so fucking funny.
Yeah, he is funny.
Well, they can take the surprise out of your voice.
No, I'm not surprised, but you have those moments where you just think about somebody.
You go, God, Andy, God, we used to have so much remember, we used to play cards
with Andy.
See, he's still alive.
Yeah.
No, I know.
I'm just saying, remember
we used to play cards
all the time back in the day.
I know, with Kyle Bass.
You know, with Kyle.
I remember Andy one time
at my old place in Venice.
Remember when he came down the stairs
and he had,
so many, Giles had brought
like fudge or something
and Andy came down and he had,
and there was fudge all around his mouth.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
And he's like, hey, I couldn't find the fudge.
I couldn't find the fudge.
And it was all.
around his mouth. He was like, it wasn't anywhere. I couldn't find it anywhere. Yeah. Jay, what did you think
about obsession? Wasn't it in a good movie? Yeah, I really liked it. Now, is that what you were watching
with my wife the other day? I was watching it with your wife in your house and you weren't there.
I was just jealous. Yeah. Oh, let me just check my phone. Scotty was there too. And Scotty was there,
yeah. Let me just see. You're going to pay for that. I know. You will pay for that one. I will pay for that.
I will pay for that one. No. You're going to text the guys after this session. You're going to say, hey, guys,
Did you trim out the little spot
where I totally forgot
that Scott was sitting next to me?
Wait, Jason, you just nodded to somebody.
Is that somebody making you an egg sandwich or something?
Ew.
Very close.
Oh, ew.
Who's there?
Thanks, Morgan.
Who's Morgan?
Morgan is my incredible partner here in...
JP?
Oh, you've got a partner now.
Look at you.
Yeah.
Yeah, she's...
Now, I have two partners here.
I don't like to say assistance.
Yeah, good for you.
Because I like to stay relatable.
Yeah, sure.
But you know who is assisting my assistant here?
Who's that?
Frannie.
Francesca Nora Bateman.
Is she there right now?
She is.
Oh, tell her we say hello.
Want to see her?
Yeah, I'll turn.
Yeah, let's hear the camera.
There she is out there in the production office.
Can he see her?
Oh yeah, look at that.
Look at her.
You're just in some lonely office.
You know, by the way, you know who stays relatable?
Mm.
People who don't say, I want to stay relatable.
Yeah.
Because they don't have to curate it.
My insincerity is bleeding through.
Yeah, man.
What is the sandwich that you got, though?
Are you going to dig into it?
I don't know.
We just push forward.
We don't talk about your net jets or...
Let's go past that.
We'll go past that.
Let's talk about that.
Or your Long Island second home.
God.
Let's talk about Nuggets.
There's Scotty.
Oh, look at Scotty.
Don't try to make up for it now, Sean.
Oh, Scott.
He's doing prey hands.
By the way, it's easy travel.
You know, you call and then they're there
and then they get you from where you need to go.
It's notches.
You should try.
Try one flight.
Not a paid ad. One flight's a better service.
Not a paid ad.
NJets.
This is disgusting.
It's so gross, guys.
Let's not cut it, though.
So, Sean, now, Sean, what did Scotty bring you?
Is that just a bowl of mixed Pop-Tarts?
No.
It's warm milk.
It's tea.
It's tea with sugar and cream.
Sugar and cream.
What kind of, even with the tea, you can't take your foot off the gas.
I think it's artificial sweetener today.
What kind of tea are we having?
Just regular English breakfast tea.
You know, there's a cake lady coming, though.
Remember the cake lady?
Well, this is not a surprise.
Yeah, but yes, I do remember.
Yeah, the cake.
So, Jay...
I don't remember.
What do you mean cake?
He's got a woman who...
I've used her.
She's amazing.
She's great.
And she'll make any cake you want.
What are you talking about?
For one of the kids' birthdays.
Yeah, she's...
We call her...
Her name is Cake Lady, but she's a real name.
Well, let's pull the relatable bus.
over to the side for a second.
No, she's like 10 bucks a cake.
You don't go down to the fucking store and buy a cake?
No, she's like 10 bucks and she delivers it.
Yeah.
She makes it and she'll deliver it to your house
and it's the best case I've ever had.
Because it's such a drag to go to a store
and put some time in to buy your child.
By the way, if anybody gets a siding of J.B. at a store,
please take a pick.
Please.
Step a pick of J.B.
And post it.
Let me tell you.
Went to Whole Foods down a camera.
There are few things that I like better
than pushing
a cart, aisle by aisle by aisle, and taking about three hours to do ten minutes of shopping.
Filed under the heading of things that never fucking happened.
I do love a good market session.
When was the last time?
I mean, last time I was in, actually, what, two days ago.
I had to run down the street to get me and my assistant's assistant some dinner.
Do you go to Whole Foods?
No, I went to this
No, this place that is...
Oh, I know that upscale marketplace.
Yeah, Meadow Lane, right?
That's a...
Yeah, Metal Lane.
By the way, that place, you would talk about relatable.
That's like the most expensive market in Triton.
But it's so convenient.
It's just down the way.
And it's so nice, it's so aesthetically...
What's it called?
It's called Meadow Lane.
It's sort of...
Sean...
It's the rich man's air one.
It's like...
Which is redundant.
It's very small, but it's incredible.
It's nice.
I don't mean to disparage the place.
It's very nice.
I know, but they've got to come down on prices.
It's going to go out of business.
You can't charge $25 for a prepackaged chicken, Chinese, whatever salad thing.
Wait, do you know what Airwan backwards is?
Yeah, man.
Nowhere?
Yeah.
Thanks.
Okay, our next guest, guys, today's guest.
Hey, if you fold a dollar bill into three things, then you'll be able to do.
see that there's a message.
You know what?
More Park is backwards.
More Park, you know the street in the valley?
Sure.
Yeah.
We tell me.
It's crap room.
Crapp room.
Wow.
My 14-year-old's going to love that.
Right?
Because she goes to school in there.
Okay.
Thanks for bringing us down.
Guys, sitting and chatting with us
today is pure sunshine on feet.
This actor-director is a woman I have had the deep
pleasure of working with twice.
Wow.
As an actor, she has done fantastic work in both comedy and drama in film, stage, and TV.
As a director, she's one of the most exciting and sought after new voices today.
And having already done three films, which no doubt there will be more, as many more, as she wants as she wishes.
She's a true friend.
Olivia Wild.
Reveal yourself, Olivia.
And today, your tasty ear meal here.
Will is Olivia Wild.
How in the world did you get that, Will?
Will.
Will, how did you get that?
Because she's one of the most sought after director is out.
Oh, of course.
Come on, of course.
That's an easy.
It's a layup.
I think you could hear my heavy breathing.
I think that's the...
Was that your small dog?
That was the last part of the intro, Jason.
It says that her heavy...
Known for her heavy breathing, right?
Wild.
Olivia, welcome to the show.
This is great.
I feel like it's long overdue.
Can we have trouble making your deal?
God, is this overdue.
What?
Well, I, everyone, I finally did every other podcast, and this was in it.
Oh.
No.
You saved the best for last in this world, right?
This is so exciting.
Sitting here spying on you guys is a really weird, thrilling feeling.
Yeah.
I apologize for all the coffee chat.
All our trash.
It's so great.
I want 45 minutes of that and three of me and then we're...
Well, you're in...
Guess what?
Yeah.
Here it comes.
It doesn't get any better.
Yeah, our favorite is to ask you a question
and then tell you what our answer is for that question
and then whatever time remains you can tell.
Oh, I know.
I'm a long-time listener.
Are you?
Big fan.
Who's your favorite?
Yeah, of course.
You're my favorite because you brought me on.
Will didn't, even though Will and I just worked together.
We did.
That's right.
Did you guys have scenes together?
We did.
Really?
Yeah.
Pivotal scene.
We don't want to say too much.
Let's go ahead. Let's start with that.
Let's tell them about your film coming out, y'all.
We're in a film called Behemoth.
I'll say.
It's behemoth.
And directed by Tony Gilroy.
The great Tony Gilroy.
The coolest.
Is the coolest guy of all time.
Hey, Will, why don't you try to book him, huh?
Yeah, why don't we get him on?
I'd love to have it.
I am going to get Tony.
We have to.
Oh, my God.
Dude.
By the way, listener, please look Tony Gilroy up and you'll be amazed.
Just his credits alone, he's just incredible.
Michael Clayton, his first film somehow, which is bananas.
That's a great movie.
Yeah, that he directed.
He's an incredible writer, but that's a perfect movie.
It's Robert Ellswitt to be the DP on that, right out of the gate.
It's crazy.
It's like Citizen Kane.
He's like, how about this?
I'll try this job, and it's perfect.
But he's so cool and so chill.
And he makes it look so easy.
I was just entirely obsessed with him and his wife.
He's got a real cool,
like you and Amanda Jason.
He's like that.
They're like just cool and obsessed with each other.
Amanda's cool.
She cares of cool for both of us.
Yeah.
Yeah, the great Tony Gilroy.
God, we love him.
We love him.
I will say, can I tell you something funny?
Olivia happened to me last week.
I want to listen.
Let me listen.
I had, well, I guess so.
This is for us.
So I had dinner with Tony like two weeks ago.
Oh, yeah.
And here in L.A.
And then I...
You talk about reshooting your stuff?
That's weird.
I was here.
But anyway, keep going.
We just got to you.
And I, we split the bill.
So we both put our cards down when we signed the thing, whatever.
We split.
Surprised you got half out of you.
Couple days later.
No, I did go through the bill.
I kept going, you had two drinks, right?
You had, did that even touch?
Who had the French?
If I'm looking at the dessert, like, I never even touched it.
And so then we spent, and then a couple days later, I go shopping to buy a few new items to get some clothes.
And the bill was pretty hefty.
And I give him the card.
The guy gets it back.
And he hands me the card back.
And I'm talking to my friend.
And I look down and it says Tony Gilroy on the credit card.
Yeah.
So I go over and then I text him.
I go, hey man.
So listen, you're about to get a big charge.
Thanks for the tops.
And so he goes, oh, shit.
And he goes, I'm going back to your IQ.
He goes, all right, I'll come over and grab it from you.
I'm right around the corner.
And he goes, he goes, I don't, I'm trying to think if I bought anything in the last couple days.
And there's a pause in the text.
And he goes, the only thing I thought,
I think I bought,
embarrassingly enough,
are mothballs.
What?
That's relatable.
So anyway,
he's got some guys got a lot of cashmere.
He's got to protect it.
He does, he does, a lot of cashmere.
He's stylish.
But this movie is starring Pedro Pescal,
and I have no idea when it comes out,
but it's going to be so good
because there are at least seven composers
on that film.
It's a film about
music and Pedro plays a cellist and you also play a musician.
Did you get to play music in the movie?
No, no.
I'm kind of...
I read it.
I think I read it.
No, I read it.
What instrument did they say your character played well?
They just said it's just a bunch.
He's just kind of like an all-around kind of...
Whatever's available?
Yeah, and he's a dude kind of...
He often, like, I don't know if you're catching my 10,000-yard stare.
The guy's got a lot going on inside, you know.
I love when you wet the reed.
Hopefully it's something for the wind instrument.
And let the spit out.
Yeah.
So truly, it's about, it's about conductors, composers.
Sort of, right?
Yeah, and like film composition, like music for film.
And it's kind of a love letter to that world.
And they show that process, which is so cool.
That's cool.
Wow.
Yeah, that is something that.
that your average movie goer does not get a chance to learn about that much.
Exactly.
It's fascinating.
It's really, really fascinating, kind of getting in and out of them.
The people who inhabit that world and what they are, and, you know,
and some of them are just the most brilliant.
And Will plays Pedro's brother.
Yeah.
Put that together in your head.
Wow.
Make that make sense.
And it does because you're that good.
It was the tan.
It's the tan that you currently have.
That's why he's still wearing all the makeup.
Thank you.
No.
You guys.
All right, well, let's...
Talk about me like I'm not here.
No.
All right.
So, we've, we've got, we started at the end.
Let's go back to the beginning.
Hey, Livy.
1942.
I don't think I've ever called you, Livy.
Now, this has gotten some press before, and I apologize to ask you about it.
But maybe some of our listeners have discussed it.
Buckle up.
But it's, but it's, but it's, it's, it's cute.
You don't like it.
You had to change your name, didn't you, doll?
I, you know, I didn't have to.
I chose to.
Well, you kind of had to.
Let's walk the audience through the original name.
Oh, yeah, I don't know this.
What's the original name?
Yeah, it's fun.
It's real fun.
It's fun.
But it's, but it's got some real lineage to it, too.
So go ahead here, guest.
You talk.
Okay, thank you so much.
I was born with a different name.
Oh.
My family name is actually.
Coburn, but it's pronounced coburn, but it's spelled.
And I'm going to, I weirdly have a visual for this.
Listener, you won't get it, but it's for these guys.
But my last name is...
Oh, wow.
Cockburn.
You were just talking about Cockburn, like two days ago.
Right?
By the way, I'm still talking about it.
When are you not talking about it?
I don't forget, but that particularly it was behind a dumpster.
Anyway, whatever.
Yeah, you had a real case of the cockburn.
I mean, if anybody has any ointment or anything,
let me know.
Wait, it's really pronounced Coburn?
It's, okay, but this is the thing.
That's not unusual.
In Scotland, it is pronounced Coburn.
I've never expected anyone in my life to ever be able to get that, to predict that.
So from me...
C-O-C-K, by his way, so people can say...
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry, C-O-C-K-B-U-R-N.
Cochburn.
Very literally how you would imagine it being spelled.
And it's a name...
to grow up with to build character.
You know, it's a boy named Sue.
And it, yeah, my family are all amazing writers and journalists and just badass people.
And that book you just held up, is that somebody from your family?
That, yeah, this is my sweet assistant has built this little tower for the microphone and she happened to use all of these books that are written by my family just to intimidate me.
That's amazing.
To remind me I haven't done shit in my life.
And they're very impressive.
But they're all amazing, yeah.
Well, then, but so A, how early did you change the name?
Right.
You landed on Wild because of your affinity for?
Oscar.
Oh, wow.
Yes, and so I changed it when I was 18.
I write when you legally can, if you can believe it.
But hang on, but you went through the toughest teasing years with that name.
Oh, yeah.
How'd that go?
I truly think it's good for you.
I think that everyone should be given one really devastating part of their name.
I was just talking to Dax about this because he also,
this was also where he wanted to start.
He was like, yeah.
We are a child of that podcast.
That's true.
I've never spoken to Dax about his name.
What do we know about, what do we know about Dax's first name?
It's actually Cockburn?
Yeah.
But like, what is, what is, is Dax?
Dax is actually his name.
No, I think it's Dax.
No, he's born Daxil, right?
I forget why his mom.
Daxil.
What was the deal with that?
What's that weird?
I've never asked him about that.
Daxil.
I have and I forget.
So, wait a minute.
Olivia, so, so, did you, so, when you, so 18, why 18?
Because, so you wanted to change it forever?
Well, no, I'm, you know, I moved out here.
I came right from boarding school.
I came right to,
and I was a casting assistant and I was doing, I was going to auditions and I was like,
I want to forge my own path and I wanted to change my name.
And I had like great affinity for other people who had done that.
I thought it was really cool when other people had done that.
And I was like, what would I do?
And the first play I did that I really loved was the importance of being earnest.
And then I read everything that Oscar Wilde wrote and I just became obsessed with.
with him and he's Irish, my family's Irish.
So that's how it happened.
Yeah, it's such a great name.
Yeah, I didn't think it would be interpreted so like pornographically.
Like the first 10 years of my career, every headline, every magazine was just like,
get wild, like, born to be wild, wet and wild.
And I was like, oh, fuck, I didn't really think this through.
Could use a little cockburn right now.
She kept it as a middle name.
I did, yeah.
No.
Wait, but what about being an assistant casting director?
Was that, now, I would imagine that would have given you some comfort as you started auditioning
that you'd kind of been on the other side of it and you kind of, was it less intimidating?
You know, I did it because Keener had done it.
Oh, really?
I was obsessed with Catherine Keener and she had done it.
Catherine Keener.
And it's not something most casting directors will let you do.
Like, they don't usually hire wannabe actors because it's like dangerous.
You have little spies in the office.
But I worked for Mally Finn.
Do you guys remember Mally?
Did you have a audition?
Yeah.
She was a legend.
And so I worked for her first when I was 16 and then when I was 18.
So when I was 16, I did it for a summer.
And then she let me come back at 18 and have a real job.
And I worked there for almost a year.
And it was wild.
I really saw how the sausage was made.
So were you outside like in the sort of reception area and watching everyone practice their faces and mop their brow?
Oh, my God.
And it was so many people I later worked with.
And I was like, I've seen you in another light when you're mad at me because it's taking too long and parking is annoying and you're late and you want coffee.
Uh-huh.
We'll be right back.
All right.
Back to the show.
Did it help you at all, like, understand the audition process?
Like, did you feel like it gave you leg up?
Yeah.
Also, she had crazy high standards.
So she would not accept anybody unprepared or not off book.
Like, she would stop people.
and say, why don't you come back
when you've done the work?
And I loved that it gave me this sense of like,
you better be really prepared.
Like I never have gone to an audition
without being prepared.
But she had crazy stories.
And the thing that I love is that
while I was working there,
there was like this great legend.
Hang on, let me drink my coffee because...
Go ahead.
We'll pause.
I'll show it right out.
Okay.
Smooth as silk.
Oh, yeah.
So while I was working there,
there was like the legend
of the Sam Rockwell audition.
And it was like,
she would tell us, like, the best audition I've ever seen was Sam Rockwell auditioning for the Green Mile.
Jason's directing him right now.
Let me tell you this, and please repeat this to him at work today.
So she said, he came in, and it was the last day of the director's sessions, the last possible day you could audition, and he came in and he had been given the wrong scenes.
And this man, Sam Rockwell, he didn't even pause. He said, well, give me the correct scenes and I'll go learn them really quick.
And they said, that's impossible, Sam.
It's 10 pages of dialogue.
You can't possibly.
No one could do it.
And he was like, just give me a chance.
I don't want to miss this opportunity.
So they gave him the right scenes.
He goes into the hallway.
They only have five minutes to give him to learn the lines.
He comes back in and he nails it.
And they were floored.
And he got the role.
And she said, that, that's an actor who can work that quickly.
So years later, I'm working with Sam and I'm sitting next to him in the makeup chair.
And I was like, Sam, it's so nice to meet you.
What an honor.
I have to tell you.
I always heard this story when I was an assistant
and it just really inspired me
and he goes, oh, yeah,
that was like a thing I used to do.
That worked every time.
Oh, really?
And I was like, are you fucking kidding me?
Oh, that's great.
I have been...
Brilliant.
Like, I thought that this...
I revered his ability to, like, flash memorize.
He knew he had the correct size.
It was a whole performance.
Oh, my God.
So, it is.
And it's so genius because it lowers their expectations.
Then if you even like say half the things right, they're like, God damn, this man learned this in five minutes.
He's a crafty bugger.
He's a real operator of that rockbacker.
I better keep my knees bent.
This is that guy.
He's like, and the way it's so standing, he's like, oh, yeah.
That's just like a thing I used to do.
Oh, yeah.
And I was like, wow.
He deserves an Oscar.
I don't know if I told this before, but we can cut this out of it's boring.
Already too boring?
No, no, we're good.
Sean, cut, pre-cut.
Pre-cut.
So I went to go audition for the bucket list
with the brilliant Rod Reiner, rest of the soul.
He was amazing.
And I walked in, and I had the wrong sides, right?
I worked on it for a long time.
And I walked in and I had all, like,
it wasn't even slightly wrong.
It was completely rewrote all these scenes.
And I started auditioning with the scene,
and he's like, what are you doing?
I'm like, what do you mean?
And he's like, who gave you these sides?
I'm my agent?
He's like, no, there's a,
a whole new script.
And he's like, I'm like, I didn't know that.
I go, great.
Then let me come back a week later and I'll go work on him.
So I work on them and I had this bit already and I walk in and it's just me and Rob and
like a couple producers and a cast writer.
And I was like, you ready?
He's like, yeah.
And then I started going, why did you order the so bad, like the horse acting you've
ever seen on purpose?
I go, why did you order the code read?
I didn't tell you to order the code red.
You want the truth.
You can't handle the truth.
No, no.
And I stopped, and he's laughing, and I go, did I get the wrong side?
That's really great.
I started doing the scene from a few good men.
That's so good.
Did he give me the part?
Yeah, I got it, yeah.
Nice.
Very nice.
So nice.
So now, Olivia, now that you're on the other side of the table in these auditions as you're directing these things, are you incredibly more compassionate?
Yes.
And I take, like, 12 hours per session because I'm like, you go.
I want to hear it all, even if I know from the first moment that it's not going to be them,
I'm like, this is your time.
And it's a disaster for everyone else because I will milk it.
It's so hard.
Auditioning is a fucking nightmare.
And these people, they come and it's so vulnerable.
And, yeah, being on that side definitely made me a little kinder.
But there's so much more also self-tapping now, right?
It's all self-tape, isn't it?
Oh, yeah.
That part seems fantastic, right?
where you can just record your audio show.
Then the pressure's off.
I like the room.
Yeah.
What if you don't do well?
What if you forget your lines?
With the self-tapes, you don't send it until you're happy with it.
But you overthink it.
I mean, can you imagine how much?
The overthinking and also what I find is when people send me tapes,
they've overthought the framing, the lighting.
People have full setups now, and I'm like, you don't need that.
I'd rather have someone's like shitty iPhone selfie video in their car
on the way to their real job,
than like a red light.
Yeah.
Rather than like a full setup that I'm like,
you didn't have to do that for me.
I don't need all this.
But Olivia, what made you,
how did you know that you wanted to just move to Los Angeles
and work in a casting director's office?
Well, truly keener.
You moved from where?
I read the keener done it.
I was at boarding school in Massachusetts.
Okay.
Who went to boarding school here?
You said somebody did.
Oh, you did?
Where did you go?
In Canada.
We don't talk about it.
We had a bad break.
Board of School and I had a bad break up.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well, mine was, it's tough, but I went to a fancy one.
I can't complain.
It was very bougie.
But I graduated and left the suburbs of Massachusetts.
After growing up in New York and then D.C.,
and I had never spent much time in the West Coast.
I thought L.A. sounded like this, like, incredible mecca of excitement.
And I came out here and took like two city buses to work every day in the casting office.
And then started auditioning and, you know, kind of like scraped my way up slowly.
But it was really the dream from the beginning.
So for me, it was very exciting.
How about that?
That's cool.
And where did you stay when you came out?
Did you move into the Oakwoods?
No, that would have been fun.
That sounded so fun for those people.
I did.
I did a few pilot seasons.
So for Tracy, that's a place where the actors would go stay when they came.
It was like a corporate housing, and there would be that thing.
I remember pilot season, you'd have like six auditions a day,
and you're not getting anything.
And the back gate is on Barham over there,
on the way down the hill towards Warner Brothers.
And on the back gate, when you leave, there's a sign on the gate,
and you had to wait for it to slowly open.
And it said, smile at showtime.
Oh, cool.
So dark.
And there'd be day, and it's like February, and it's raining all day,
and you're, like, going back for a crappy pilot,
and you're just feeling like, I'm like,
Oh, so hard.
I'm worthless.
I'm 31, nothing is happening.
Smile, it's show time.
Fuck me, man.
Well, I had given myself a limit
because I had taken a, I deferred from college
and I was like, I'm giving myself a year
or like nine months.
And if I don't book anything in that time,
I'll go.
I think that's good.
I think giving yourself a little bit of a deadline.
What was the thing that you would have gone back
and studied in college?
I mean, acting.
I mean, it would have, I think
I think I would have studied, I really probably would have become a writer like everyone else in my
family or I would have tried.
But now if I went back, which I like to fantasize about, I think it would be like completely,
I think I want to study neuroscience.
I'd like to go and do, wouldn't that be cool?
There'd be a bunch of math I'd have to catch up on though, which is not.
I've got a couple of friends that are doctors and I just, they walk on water to me.
I just like, that's really, like, you certainly aren't born with any sort of natural talent to
cut people's brains open and fix it.
Right?
Like you could be born with talent to throw a football 100 yards or whatever, but you don't
come out with it.
So it's all learned.
You have to learn so much and you don't learn it until you read it or it's explained to you.
Jason respects discipline.
He respects discipline.
Yes.
And self-education.
I just,
I think it's incredible.
I wonder if they are born though with something.
Maybe you are born with.
Well, you just have to, an affinity to want.
Yeah, or learn.
That's why I'd get into neuroscience because I'd want to get in there and see if they are born with it.
Like, you know what I mean?
Yeah.
Get in.
You cut them open and look for natural talent.
Yeah, you fucking dummy.
That's why I'm doing it.
Yeah.
You think Dr. Gary walks on water, by the way?
I do.
He's an emergency room physician.
No, you disrespect his golf game because he's so straight and he's always in the fair way.
But what about, I have a friend that's like, he's like, I don't trust doctors.
I don't believe in them.
I think, you know, statins.
Like, just, he goes on and on about, like, what...
You're talking about RFK Jr.?
Yeah.
Your top dog?
Yeah, he's...
I'm having dinner with him tonight.
No.
Top dog.
No, but, like, what do you think about these people
who don't ever...
Who constantly put doctors down?
I'm with you.
I'm like, I've taken the two choices
about someone who, you know,
stuff you read online or, like, self-help, whatever,
and somebody who's studying...
it day in and day out, I'm going to go with the guy who studied it.
Yeah, just assuming that those doctors must be wrong.
Like, wait, what?
Also, there's a bigger conspiracy at play here that they're looking to take the,
what does it, take the world over?
They've all organized and figured out how to trick us all.
Sean, do you think Sean trust doctors too much.
I mean, I would say that maybe.
Yeah, he's got a punch card at Cedars.
No, he's, they call him paddles when he comes in.
He's got a-fid and he's always getting it fired up.
I mean, I had to play a doctor to be anywhere near it.
House.
Let's talk about house.
That wasn't me trying to like segue into my career at all.
No, no.
We appreciate the help.
And for our Canadian listeners, it's the show known as House.
Yes, created by Canadians.
Wasn't that next door to us over there on the Fox Lott for arrest development?
I thought you meant Canada.
Oh, man.
I wish I was on your show.
I wish we were all back on the 20th lot.
Wasn't that great?
Just going to Apple Pan every day for lunch.
Apple Pans for my life.
Is that still there?
Oh, yeah.
Apple Pan.
I think it is there.
I think Irving Azov by Apple Pan.
Didn't Irving Azov by Apple Pan? Or is that?
Or am I thinking of Nate Niles?
You're correct.
Sean, you go there after therapy.
So like once all the feelings come up, you go to stuff them back down?
Yes.
With the tuna melt and the milkshake.
So good.
Fries.
All right.
So we're back.
We go back in the time machine.
What is Olivia Co-Bose?
When she's a wee lass that's inspiring her to become an actor.
Okay, this is the thing.
I think about this a lot now.
My family, we watched a lot of comedy together.
And it is my greatest memory from childhood is the sound of my parents laughing and all of us laughing.
And my mom has a really funny thing.
She's still like cries when she laughs.
And it's just adorable.
She always always to be like wiping away tears and my dad laughing so hard.
All of us.
And when I think about it,
It was a lot of comedy that I wouldn't have been absorbing the real meaning of.
I mean, a lot of...
Like taxi, all the family.
Yeah, and like, we watched, like, a lot of comedy that was probably little too adult.
And then a lot of, you know, we watched, like, Wayne's World a thousand times.
Like, for some reason, Wayne's World was, like, a huge movie in our family.
But a lot of SNL.
And it was a real joy to just sit and watch, you know, all the Monty Python together.
a lot.
Like we just, it was the best.
And I think for me, watching comedy,
even watching, like, for me, I love Lucy.
I watch a lot of old comedy television.
Yeah, we do too.
I do too.
I watch Cheers a lot.
Cheers, the best.
I love cheers.
God, I love cheers.
And so I think about, like,
oh, of course that's where I find myself
now wanting to make comedies
because it's just,
I think it is probably the happiest memories from childhood.
I think I'm trying to recreate that feeling.
But did you go like,
Oh, I'm going to go and do this and I want to be in comedy?
Like, was that like a thing?
Yes, yes.
Yeah, I think probably because I probably at the earliest stage
saw how happy it was making my parents.
Like I think, and then I would, I was the ham of the family.
And so I would make them laugh.
And then I would, I was the Hamun of the family.
And I would go and like just entertain everyone.
And they always had parties.
My parents were very social and very good hosts.
And so they had these amazing parties all the time.
and it was my joy in life to go and, like, perform as the little kid.
So, but I really think it was from watching all these great movies together.
And I think about it because I'm like, am I showing my kids enough, like, great films?
I hope so.
Jason, you're good about it with Frannie.
You've been so good about that.
I put them in front of the TV before they could even speak because that was my upbringing.
I mean, that did, like, you know.
Because you were playing golf.
Well, there was that.
You're busy.
But, you know, they got to learn somehow, you know,
colors and numbers and things.
You've talked to the last couple of years.
Like you and Frannie talk about film and you sort of put a lot of good stuff in front
of her.
Like that's been important to you.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, really important to me.
Because that's what I had with my dad.
It was great subject matter and shared references.
And yeah, I just, I love it.
Yeah, you don't want to expose your four-year-old to the wire.
No.
You know, it's just like common sense.
I'm not afraid of screens.
It's the best.
And when they get it, it's so great.
but sometimes they'll be like,
they'll come back from their dad's house
and be like, we had to watch 12 Angry Men.
And I'm like,
geez, I don't know if that's...
Well, Suds, you know.
Suds loves the 12 Angry Men.
Otis is like, oh, my God.
What are your kids, what are your go-to,
whether they're repeats,
like they'll watch the same one movie over and over.
Oh, well, I miss when they were really into, like,
musical theater.
I mean, Otis used to be obsessed with singing in the rain
and it was so sweet he would watch.
watch it over and over and over again.
And, you know, Mary Poppins and all that's...
And now...
Now it's more...
Actually, the thing that I love that he's into is Godzilla,
the old Godzilla's.
Oh, no, with like the claymation...
Yeah, like Mothra.
Have you seen that?
The 1960s Godzilla's are so cool and beautiful.
And he and I went to Japan a couple weeks ago
on like a little mom-son trip.
We went for a week.
I'm so jealous.
And it was the best.
It was like, it was just the greatest trip I've ever taken with another person alone.
Like it was, we laughed constantly.
And it was, it came from our shared Godzilla obsession.
Can I just say as an aside, have you guys been to Japan before, Sean?
No, I want to go.
I've been a couple times as a kid.
And I have actually promised that exact trip Olivia just took to both girls individually,
just father-daughter time.
And I have not done it yet.
You got to go with Abel, the same thing.
Japan is the great.
greatest place.
I couldn't love Japan anymore.
It's amazing.
And it's great for kids.
It's clean. It's so clean.
Like, Otis couldn't get over the fact that there's no trash on the street and there's no trash cans.
So it's not because, like, oh, they have so many trash cans.
It's that they just respect the city enough to not litter.
It's the everything about it is interesting and beautiful.
And we had the best time.
We got on the bullet train.
And every, you, I bet you love it, Bateman, because.
it's very efficient.
Everything about it.
Like the train leaves like literally like to the second at the time that it says.
It's like the opposite of Italy.
Even and I love Italy too.
But it's like.
We went for a train.
Yeah.
It is.
And Otis is like that.
It's coming.
Yeah.
Make a big deal.
Have a nice coffee.
One cigarette.
It's predictable.
And I think kids really like that too.
They like the idea that like it's going to happen when they say it's going to happen.
And they're just so, they're just the coolest.
Well, I saw this thing about Japan where if a kid, I may have gotten this wrong,
if a kid is wearing yellow, then that kid is by himself and everybody watches out for that kid.
Come on.
Oh, my God.
Like the kid isn't, doesn't have a.
Unchaperone, unschapron, yeah.
Wow.
Or an orphan, perhaps.
Maybe that's an orphan uniform.
Right.
Just walking around looking for a home.
This one's free.
Just grab this one if you want.
No?
I don't think so
Oh,
No, but I think I saw that
I don't know if that's true
I don't know about that one
It's probably not
Oh hang on this is a segment we like to call it
I think I saw that
It's just really a lot of conjecture
It's next to the other segment
I think I saw that
Scrub My Search History by Sean Hayes
Wait we have to introduce that
I may have dreamt this
All right, so here we go.
What was the thing?
What was the job?
What was the thing that turned it all?
Because you're auditioning, you're doing so.
What was the thing?
What was the first boom?
I guess probably the OC.
The OC.
Oh, that's right.
I was a bisexual bartender, Alex Kelly.
And it was a big show.
Bigger than I knew it was when I agreed to do it.
And it was wild.
You know, it's being rewatched now.
Oh, I know.
Because these young folks, now they come up to me and I'm like, what do you mean?
It's such a deep cut, but they will say like, I love you on the show.
And I'm like, what show?
And it's the O.C.
And I can't believe it.
I mean, for them, it's like Nick at Night now, right?
It's like old.
I wonder why they landed on that as opposed to, let's say, 90210 or Melrose Place or...
It's close enough.
And also, they're obsessed with early aughts everything fashion now, too.
So, like, it's, it is from that era that is now weirdly coming back.
And so they're into that look and the music.
It's relevant again.
Sean, you're about to be in style again.
Oh, jeez.
I mean, this is the good thing that's going to pay off.
Yeah, you're like low-rise jeans and your little crop tops.
Yeah.
It's coming back.
The thing in the mirror behind you coming up is, it's closer than it looks.
We'll be right back.
And back to the show.
All right, and then there was girl next door,
there was Alpha Dog, and then we got to Cowboys and Aliens.
I love that movie.
Change Up.
When are we getting to the Change Up?
I mean, were there more people that saw Cowboys and Aliens or Change Up?
Oh, that's hard.
It might have been the same five people.
Let's talk about the change up.
Let's talk about it.
Favorite memory of the change up.
My favorite memory is obviously sitting on your lap.
Poplis.
With pasties.
No, I mean from shooting.
I mean from the movie.
Oh, okay.
That was also fun.
Yeah.
That was a good time as well.
We really had the best time.
I loved making that movie.
Right?
It was a blast.
Ryan's the coolest.
David Dobkin was so freaking awesome.
Oh, Dobkin.
It was really fun.
Down there in Atlanta.
I loved it.
Remember when I stopped by on the set?
At the same time, yeah, Sean, you were making three stooges at the same time.
Yes, you were.
And I walked to the mall to go see Green Lantern.
And there's Jason and Ryan filming Change Up in the middle of the mall.
Oh, wow.
And I walked right into the middle of the scene.
I was like, hey, guys.
Oh, they should have kept that.
Movie would have been better.
With the curly wig on?
Yeah, totally.
At the fountain.
I think it was the fountain right in the middle of the mall.
Oh, right, the fountain.
You guys were so good.
You were so funny together.
You got a bogey over by the fountain.
Totally.
I was shuffled along very quickly.
And then we do
Drinking Buddies, Joe Swanberg.
Yes.
That was completely improvised.
Completely improvised.
Yeah, that's like the true
Swannbergian way,
which is kind of that mumblecore,
which I think they hate that word,
mumblecore, seems very, I don't know.
It's more than it is.
It says a mumble, mumbo.
I don't know.
I got a mumblecour.
It was, there's no script, there's a sort of outline,
and then you just improvise.
What is this for?
Oh, this was a movie called Drinking Buddies.
Oh, Drinky Buddies.
Isn't that similar to what they do on a curb your enthusiasm?
Shawnee, you've done that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is it all?
So there's no written script.
No, zero.
You just got to hit the beats and then you start.
It's super fun.
It's so great.
And it was the first time I kind of took myself seriously
as potentially being able to write something
or maybe direct something one day
because we were really in control of the story.
And it was a collective effort.
And that workshop was so fun.
It makes it very real.
And it was, we kept learning from what happened
and then letting that affect the next scene.
So it was like, oh, now this would happen to these people.
It was a shot in order.
We shot it mostly in order.
And that led to then the movie that I just directed,
this movie The Invite that I did completely in order.
And it was all really started in Drinking Buddies days
when I was like, this is so fun.
And it was a dream.
I loved making that movie.
In Chicago, drinking beer.
I love that.
So that was my next question.
So did Drinking Buddies inspire you to want to direct?
Yeah.
Is that the experience?
I kind of, I wanted to do before,
but that was the first time that I was like,
wait, I think I might know how to put a scene together
because I was given the chance to sort of be a part of that process
and it was, I was like, this is the most fun.
And now having done both obviously scripted
and this version where it's improv through an outline,
do you prefer one of the other?
I think there's a, what I prefer is what I ended up getting to do on this movie,
which was we workshopped the script together as cast and writers.
And then we were able to shoot an order,
yeah, it was like a play.
and it was a very well-thought-out script ultimately,
but we had kind of worked it together,
and not in a full, like, Mike Lee way
where we spent like a year improvising on a cliffside
or something, it's not that.
But it was very organic because we had come,
we had really massaged it together,
and then once we got on set,
we knew exactly what we were doing.
I like that.
Well, so tell the audience a little bit more about that one.
This was called The Invite,
and it's inspired by or based on
It's based on a Spanish film.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
So, yeah, so tell me, how did it kind of get started?
Who watched the film first?
Come on.
Who called each, who called the other person and say, you know, let's do it this way?
Okay, so Rashida Jones and Will McCormick wrote, we love, wrote the English language adaptation of a Spanish film that was called The People Upstairs.
And it was a small Spanish film that was based on a play.
that you can sort of see the origins of it as a play
because it's four people in one apartment,
and that's the whole thing takes place
with four people in one apartment over one night.
And the idea is that it's kind of a dinner party gone wrong.
It's about a husband and wife,
in our version, it's myself and Seth Rogen,
who have been kind of plagued by the sounds
of our neighbors upstairs having very loud sex,
and it's been driving Seth's character kind of insane.
and unbeknownst to him, I've invited these people over for dinner,
and he's furious because he doesn't want to have dinner with anyone.
He's tired from work, but he says, fine, if you've ambushed me with this,
I'm going to bring up the noise from upstairs.
And I'm like, over my dead body, you'll bring up that noise.
You will not, please just try to be normal
and have a normal night so we can have friends.
And so the whole night, he's kind of threatening to bring up this thing,
and they are endlessly kind of sexy and enigmatic,
and they end up really blowing our minds
and changing our marriage in one night.
And the other couple is?
Penelope Cruz and Edward Norton.
A cast.
Unbelievable cast.
It's insane.
And so Rashida and Will wrote the English version,
and I got that script,
and I was like, this is hilarious.
And it was clearly an opportunity
to make something in this way
that I had been obsessing over since Drinking Buddies.
So I was like, okay, we can shoot this in order,
and we can really personalize this
script together and workshop it and make it really specific to these actors. And we can shoot it on 35
millimeter and we can make it really fun. And I'm obsessed with Mike Nichols. So I was like, this can be
our Virginia Woolf. And it was the best experience of my life. Sorry, Jason. And Will, we, I love
working with you guys. This one was great. But then, so you take this great script from Rashida and Will
but then the four of you get together, the cast,
and do you guys start to take an even plus the script
because of the specificity of each actor?
Yes, and we really, the six of us sat for two weeks.
This was the thing.
I was like, can we stop giving away rehearsal time immediately
when we make movies?
Like, it's the first thing we give up.
We were just talking about this recently.
Impossible to convince people.
Really agents.
Agents are the ones who are like, no, he's not available
until the minute you start rolling the camera.
And he's like, why?
Why can't we consider it part of the job?
Can you imagine doing that for theater?
If it was like, no, I'll be there for previews.
Then what they do is then they pro rate their salary.
They say, well, so an extra two weeks of work at this number.
Jason's also an agent.
I don't know if you knew that.
Yeah, be my agent, please.
But it really was so fun
because the six of us sat at this table
and we tore through the script
and Rashid and Will
were so game to
kind of let it evolve to what these actors were thinking.
God, that's fun. And it was so fun, and it was like,
imagine, I mean, Seth and Edward and Penelope
are all real filmmakers on their own.
I mean, they're directors, they're writers,
and so the opportunity to kind of get all of their good ideas
and put them in there.
And Edward, Edward is on another...
First of all, Edward's maybe one of my favorite,
smartless guests.
He's, maybe that episode is really great.
I love him so much.
Well, he's so smart.
He's so funny.
Yeah, and he's so funny.
And people don't even,
people do know it.
But I'm obsessed with him.
And he ended up improvising
like an entire monologue
in the third act of this movie
that is so beautiful.
And it really just,
it was his gift to us
to just kind of like,
he said to me,
I'm gonna,
I have a story I want to tell on the scene.
I kind of don't,
want to tell you what it is.
And I was like, okay, yeah, how long, like, roughly?
Just because we're, like, rolling film and I was paying for the film and I was like,
just like, how, how?
Was it longer than a full mag?
I put a thousand-foot bag on the camera and I was like, go, and he used it.
And it was really great.
But it was, Penelope Cruz came up with the funniest set piece in the movie.
And it was all with the, you know, workshopping with Rashida and Will who would,
man, just like run with the punches of roll or run?
Do you roll or you roll with them?
You don't roll with the punch, yeah.
They roll and ran.
They ran with the ball.
It was the best.
And then I wasn't supposed to be in the movie,
but the actors bullied me into playing that part,
which was very sweet of them.
Well, now, how do you find that?
Do you find it efficient to direct yourself,
or do you find it distracting?
I think in this case it was efficient
because it was so intimate.
It was almost like having one less body on set
was actually really helpful.
And I think that it allowed me to see things they were all doing.
These geniuses were doing so many little things
that I could see things the camera couldn't see.
And so I'd be like, oh, okay, now we need to come around
because Seth is doing something that I actually need us to get.
And so in that way, it was good.
I feel like it could be very difficult in a different situation.
I also was playing someone who was, like, riddled with anxiety,
which helped.
because I could just kind of be me.
Were they comfortable with you directing them inside a take,
or did you have to wait until you yelled cut before you gave them notes?
I wasn't, I didn't do a like, okay, give me a little more, give me a little, like in this,
still rolling, I'm still rolling, I want more, go deeper.
I didn't do that at all.
In character, directed in character.
Yeah, yeah.
No, I really believe in letting people kind of play and try things,
and then knowing that what I,
really can do as a director is later on prune and adjust things in the edit.
So I just think it was encouraging them to keep experimenting.
And with Seth, I would have to tell him he could be meaner to me because our characters,
it's a very contentious relationship and there's a lot of arguing.
And he's a very non-confrontational person.
So the most direction I gave Seth was like, you can fucking scream at me.
Like I can take it.
And angry Seth is a thing to behold.
Because he's got it in him.
It turns out.
How many days was it then?
It must have been.
23.
Amazing.
Yeah, so fast.
Wow.
And like just the best.
I mean, we were on this little soundstage,
Sunset Las Palmas.
It's the pink one.
If you remember the opening of the player
when he drives in, it's that.
And it's iconic.
It's great and tiny.
And we were all, we built the set on stage
and we just, you know, banged it out.
And then a year later went to Sundance.
It was so fast.
We get in the weeds for one.
One second.
Did you have multiple cameras?
Oh.
We had one camera.
No.
And then towards the last week, we brought in a second camera because we wanted to just be able to,
there were some scenes that they benefited from two cameras.
But I didn't want to.
I felt like I had been inspired by like Tarantino saying, like, don't be a hack.
Have one camera.
Pick your perspective.
Anytime you have two cameras, one shot is suffering.
And I was like, oh, that's cool.
Well, but you've got these four people talking all the time,
and so you've got to do it four times at least
so that everyone gets a camera pointed at them.
Yes.
We did a lot of shared frame.
That's why it is very theatrical in that way
that there's a lot of times we're sharing the frame,
which is why we had the best focus puller in the world
who could somehow predict when someone was going to improvise a joke.
And it's also better, I think, for comedy
because there's nothing worse than cutting back
between, you know, from singles in comedy.
love seeing people inhabiting the same frame in a comic.
Oh, it's so thrilling because they really did that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's so much better.
So if you take a left on Las Palma, it's like street parking, obviously,
again, Jason, I know that you want.
Where'd the trucks go?
Also, editing comedy, too, I just find, I always think, you know,
I gave you or whoever it is, they gave you the comedy timing
while you were filming it.
And the editor plays with it.
It's like, no, we gave you.
the timing when we were filming it.
Yes.
That's what it is.
Exactly.
It's a tough thing to maintain.
Yeah.
God.
It's why Wonders are so good.
Exactly.
Because they're just fully intact.
But you had so much
technique and know-how
and execution
right out of the gate with Booksmart
was like,
just like a stunning accomplishment.
That must have felt so good.
The movie's so good.
That was your first movie you directed?
Yeah.
It's insane.
I think that,
It really was because my proxy film school,
because I didn't go to college,
didn't go to film school,
and I was always insecure about that lack of education.
And I think that being on so many sets as an actor,
I just paid attention to everything,
and I just tried to absorb it.
But yeah, I think Booksmart,
I think often your first movie is the one you've been building up
for your entire life,
and you put all of your ideas into it,
and you have so much to give.
and you're lucky if it resonates with people.
And I got so lucky because it happened to hit, you know,
a place in a lot of people's kind of shared trauma of adolescence.
Like, that's the thing I love about high school movies.
But even just the making of it, Olivia, like, you know,
and the stuff that you wouldn't have been around to observe
and to sort of cherry-pick from these great directors,
all this post-incredbleness in that film.
the editing style, the choice and the use of music and stuff like,
that's all shit that people usually need like a handful of movies under their belt
before they really kind of, I don't know, I just was so happy.
Again, the science of it is you're born with it, you're born with it.
Yeah, we're going to cut you open and take a look.
Yeah, get in there.
I love it.
I'm a much better director than actor, but I love acting too, but directing,
I do.
Guys, tell me, am I wrong?
Are you?
No, you're right.
No, I just love it.
You paused after you said that.
I did.
I was like, uh.
So, Olivia, what, what's going on when you're not working?
Pickleball or what?
Oh, no.
Should I learn it?
Fuck.
No.
I was in Central Park the other day and they were playing it.
And someone was playing like Jimmy Hendrix, the stereo and like, everybody was playing
pickleball.
And I was like, what a beautiful hobby that I don't do.
But I like to watch.
Yeah.
I don't know.
What is the hobby someone would be?
surprise to learn that you've got.
It's just us.
No one's listening.
No, it's just us.
Between us, gals.
Yeah, or the pastime,
or like the guilty TV or the thing.
Do you have a thing that you do?
You're like, oh my God,
I can't believe I'm wasting my time doing this.
I don't really.
I mean, hobbies, yeah.
I mean, I feel like I'm really recently,
it's like I'm working or I'm mothering.
Yeah.
And.
What's the dumbest thing that you do?
Because like, you know, the directing is like,
you can't stop thinking because you,
there's never,
right.
You've never have it all figured out.
So, like, what do you do that requires zero thinking?
Do you ever just stare at the television and let it just talk to you?
Yeah.
Yeah, I love.
Will you get wrapped up in crap?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I just watched Love is Blind.
Oh, God, it's great.
So good.
I did four hours of below deck yesterday.
You did?
I did four full hours of below deck yesterday.
I did a 90-day fiancé before the 90 days.
Oh, oh.
I've done a bunch of episodes.
Wow.
Olivia, any reality?
I mean, I love love on the spectrum.
That makes me cry, and I love it so much.
Incredible.
And, no, I mean, I love a housewife.
But I think that for me, it's like...
Oh, any city on housewives.
I mean, I like Beverly Hills, but I think that any city will do it for me.
Yeah.
But I think that, like, I just watched all of love story, and I got really into it.
It's not, that's the Ryan Murphy.
That's the...
Carolyn Bassett.
Right, right, right, right.
Got really into that.
And it's not quite reality TV,
but you still feel like a little,
there's something a little guilty pleasure about it.
I haven't watched that,
but the only bummer about that love story to me is that it's made.
They die in the end?
No, it's made Odeon really busy again in Tribeca.
Oh, my God, that's true.
I'm like, oh, all these people are coming.
What that's cool?
Oh, get out of here.
Oh, that's the restaurant we ate at.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Before we let you go, because we're coming up on the end here.
It's so fast.
This is crazy.
Holy shit.
Talk to us about another new thing coming up called I Want Your Sex.
I do.
I want your sex.
Right?
All right.
It is.
Got our clip.
That is, I want it.
That is Greg Araki, who is a real, like, very cool filmmaker, who is a real L.A.
filmmaker.
He is an autort.
And wild.
I mean, very, very much an individual.
And I play a dominatrix.
And, of course.
And I get to...
Who are you dominating?
You're dominating the sweet little Cooper Hoffman.
You know, he doesn't deserve to get whipped.
He loved it.
And it is a very, very campy fun movie.
And it was really cool because when we were at Sundance with the invite,
I Want Your Sex premiered on Friday, and the invite was Saturday.
and I just felt so lucky to be able to be a part of this fun business
where we get to tell all these crazy stories
and they both got bought magically and so and they're coming out right after each other
and it's so fun yeah it's like invite in them out so I want your sex comes out July 23rd
which is in about 10 days from this air date here and the invite is out
invites already out.
Yeah, it came out June 26.
June 26, New York.
You're not on my birthday, guys.
Now you have plans.
No, we have plans.
I mean, you did plans.
We saw it.
Yeah, on my birthday.
That was my birthday.
And you had the best time
and everyone laughed so hard.
Yes, I loved it.
Oh, I'm glad you loved it.
Your favorite film, come on.
Of all time?
You liked the beginning and you loved the middle
but you really was the end.
She shed a tear.
Yeah.
I walked out and not dry.
And then we're going to all look forward to the behemoth with sweet, sweet Willie Arnett,
coming out sometime next year, right?
At some point.
Meanwhile, you're probably hard at work, getting ready to direct your next incredible movie.
We're all waiting for it.
Please be in it.
You're the best.
Can you just give us a hint of what you're working on in an area or no?
It's a comedy.
It's a Christmas comedy.
I'm in.
I'm already in.
I love a Christmas comedy.
You should see Sean play an elf.
He did it with Kenny Rogers.
He was on the road with Kenny Rogers.
Yeah.
Please come be in a self-tape over with real good lighting.
Yes.
I'll actually put myself in a winter wonderland just so you really get it.
Yeah, yeah.
Great.
What was your line?
Santa, I don't know when to hold them or when to fold them.
Fold them.
That's what it was.
We love you, Olivia.
I love you guys.
Thank you for having me.
What a dream.
And congrats on everything.
Yeah, super, super congrats.
Thank you.
Keep going.
girl. Thanks.
Bye.
See you soon.
Wow.
That's the incredibly charming.
Olivia Wilde.
Love her.
You can tell she's funny.
She's super funny.
Super funny.
So smart.
So, so smart.
And so cool.
I'm just so excited that she's directing and that it's just like,
she could like just do it forever, you know?
But, like, she's incredible out.
She's got every gear.
She's got a director, actor.
And they're all working.
I know.
They're all working, yeah.
All the gear.
I'd love to have a gear.
It would be nice.
A gear.
She's got it all.
You know?
What are you doing?
What are you doing with your life?
Well, I don't know.
I tell you what I am doing on October 17th.
What do you, what's that?
Well, if you go to smartless.com slash live, you'll find out what I'm doing.
And it has to do with the Hollywood Bowl.
I'll just say that.
Oh, what's happening?
What's happening?
that smartless.com slash live has to do with the Hollywood Bowl.
What do you mean?
And you know what?
I'm going to invite you guys.
What?
Join me.
I'm available.
Yeah.
What are we going to be doing?
We're going to do a live smartless show at the Hollywood Bowl.
Smartless.com slash live on October 17th.
It's going to be.
So it's going to be off the...
Fwp, Fwap.
Hollywood Bowl.
Oh, wow.
Listen, what we're going to do is we're going to, you know, the New York's got the...
Okay, here we go.
Finally, Jason's got one.
New York's got the apple.
L.A.'s got the orange.
And so what we're going to do is since, you know, the Hollywood Bowl is such a big part of L.A.,
we're going to go ahead and take a big...
Out of the orange, we're going to take a big bite.
The worst ever.
Smart.
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf.
Smartless.
© PodScripts.co - Podcast transcripts and discussion
Privacy Policy
if (document.readyState !== 'loading') {
run();
} else {
document.addEventListener('DOMContentLoaded',function () {
run();
});
}
// Banner Analytics Tracking
function run() {
const banners = document.querySelectorAll('.ad-container img');
let impression_checks = new Set();
// Create intersection observer
const observer = new IntersectionObserver((entries) => {
entries.forEach(entry => {
if (entry.isIntersecting) {
const banner = entry.target;
const bannerContainer = banner.closest('.ad-container');
const bannerId = bannerContainer.dataset.bannerId;
if (bannerId && !impression_checks.has(bannerId)) {
impression_checks.add(bannerId);
axios.post('/api/banner-analytics/track', {
banner_id: bannerId,
event_type: 'impression',
page_url: window.location.href
}).catch(error => {
console.error('Error tracking impression:', error);
});
}
}, {
threshold: 0.5, // Trigger when 50% of the banner is visible
rootMargin: '0px'
});
// Observe all banners
banners.forEach(banner => {
observer.observe(banner);
});
// Track clicks
banners.forEach(banner => {
const bannerContainer = banner.closest('.ad-container');
if (bannerContainer) {
bannerContainer.addEventListener('click', function(e) {
const bannerId = this.dataset.bannerId;
if (bannerId) {
axios.post('/api/banner-analytics/track', {
banner_id: bannerId,
event_type: 'click',
page_url: window.location.href
}).catch(error => {
console.error('Error tracking click:', error);
});
}
window.dataLayer = window.dataLayer || [];
function gtag()
gtag('js', new Date());
gtag('config', 'G-WLY98RVSV3');
console.log(window.scroll_to_words);
function readMoreLess() {
var dots = document.getElementById("dots");
var moreText = document.getElementById("more");
var btnText = document.getElementById("readMoreButton");
if (dots.style.display === "none") {
dots.style.display = "inline";
btnText.innerHTML = "Read more";
moreText.style.display = "none";
} else {
dots.style.display = "none";
btnText.innerHTML = "Read less";
moreText.style.display = "inline";
}
setTimeout(function (){
document.querySelectorAll('ins[data-ad-status="filled"]').forEach(async (ad) => {
if (getComputedStyle(ad).getPropertyValue('position') === 'fixed' && getComputedStyle(ad).getPropertyValue('display') === 'block' && getComputedStyle(ad).getPropertyValue('bottom') === '0px') {
document.querySelector('#main_pod_player_parent').style.bottom = getComputedStyle(ad).getPropertyValue('height')
}
});
}, 2300);
$(document).ready(function(){
if($('.country-text').length) {
$('.country-text').click();
}
});
// Function to check if URL has show_ads parameter
function hasShowAds() {
return window.location.search.includes('show_ads=true');
}
// Function to add show_ads parameter to a URL
function addShowAdsToUrl(url) {
if (!url) return url;
try {
const urlObj = new URL(url, window.location.origin);
urlObj.searchParams.set('show_ads', 'true');
return urlObj.toString();
} catch (e) {
console.error('Error processing URL:', e);
return url;
}
// Function to process all internal links
function processInternalLinks() {
if (!hasShowAds()) return;
// Process all anchor tags
document.querySelectorAll('a').forEach(link => {
const href = link.getAttribute('href');
if (href && !link.classList.contains('exist-ad-preview') && !href.startsWith('http') && !href.startsWith('mailto:') && !href.startsWith('tel:') && !href.startsWith('?show_ads=true')) {
link.href = addShowAdsToUrl(href);
}
});
// Process all forms
// document.querySelectorAll('form').forEach(form => {
//     const action = form.getAttribute('action');
//     if (action && !action.startsWith('http')) {
//         form.action = addShowAdsToUrl(action);
//     }
// });
}
// Run on page load
document.addEventListener('DOMContentLoaded', processInternalLinks);
// Run when content is dynamically added
const observer = new MutationObserver((mutations) => {
mutations.forEach((mutation) => {
if (mutation.addedNodes.length) {
processInternalLinks();
}
});
observer.observe(document.body, {
childList: true,
subtree: true
});
document.addEventListener('DOMContentLoaded', function() {
const adElement = document.querySelector('.site_wide-ads');
const container = document.querySelector('.container');
const headerHeight = 80; // Height of the header in pixels
let originalTop = 0;
let isSticky = false;
if (adElement) {
// Store the original position
originalTop = adElement.getBoundingClientRect().top + window.pageYOffset;
function handleScroll() {
const scrollTop = window.pageYOffset || document.documentElement.scrollTop;
if (scrollTop > originalTop - headerHeight && !isSticky) {
// Make sticky
adElement.style.position = "fixed";
adElement.style.top = headerHeight + "px";
adElement.style.width = container.offsetWidth + "px";
isSticky = true;
} else if (scrollTop